how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we waited a very long time to get the
title for Avengers end game in fact
Marvel didn't give us the title until we
got the trailer for Avengers in game
after the trailer was released where
they revealed the title they soon after
he gave us the typical Avengers logo and
not too long after that they came out
with a new logo for Avengers and game
for marketing as you can see this
marketing logo is fairly different than
the one that they put out right after
the trailer was released as you can see
this logo is purple and gold and what
it's really calling to here is Thanos if
you remember the Russo brothers said
that Avengers infinity war and Avengers
in game are movies that are about Thanos
and this logo seems to be bringing that
point back what this is really pointing
to here is Thanos and his golden armor
the Russo brothers explained that Thanos
wears his armor going into battle we
even saw it at the beginning of infinity
war on Thor's ship and we saw it during
the flashback scene with Gamora the
Russo brothers then go on to explain
that Thanos takes off his armor once he
gets more than one Infinity stone
because when he collects more than one
Infinity stone he now feels like he's
more powerful and doesn't need the armor
so the logo is calling back to Thanos
wearing his golden armor and if this
points to Thanos putting on his golden
armor again then that says a lot about
the condition that Thanos is currently
in we know that the snap permanently
damaged Thanos and the Infinity Gauntlet
and left him and the gauntlet in a very
weakened state and we know this because
the Russo brothers who directed Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame said
so and we even get a glimpse of this in
the avengers in-game teaser trailer we
see fan house on his new home walking in
a cornfield with the damaged Infinity
Gauntlet still on his hand but noticed
that he's not even wearing his normal
clothes that he had on underneath the
armor he's wearing farmer clothes and
the way he's walking it looks like he's
sort of limping you can tell that he's
hurt and he hung up his armor on the
Scarecrow so he's clearly hurt and this
logo points to him putting on his armor
again and the reason that he's actually
going to put the armor on again is
because he's hurt and he doesn't think
he's strong enough to take on the
Avengers again without it but is he
really that hurt hurt enough to put his
armor on again even though
he's hurt with all of the Infinity
stones he's still way more powerful than
all of the Avengers so since he's
putting his armor back on what this
likely means is that at some point
Thanos loses one or more Infinity stones
and this will most likely come from time
travel because right now
nobody knows where feyo's is he went off
on a distant planet so the Avengers most
likely go back in time and alter the
events so that Thanos doesn't have all
the Infinity stones this sort of depends
on how you view time but I can see fan
OHS just sitting on his farm and then
all of a sudden an infinity stone
disappears at first this might not
disturb Thanos too much but when a
second stone disappears he'll start to
realize what the Avengers are doing
he'll realize that the Avengers are
trying to get the stones themselves and
undo the snap but now he'll be down a
couple of stones and he's hurt so he'll
put the armor back on that's what this
logo is pointing to Thanos putting back
on his golden armor what do you all
think about famous as weakened state and
what do you think is going to happen to
make him put back on his armor let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and I'm currently giving away a
life-sized Infinity Gauntlet all you
have to do to enter for your chance to
win is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]